[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
und zwar war das 1981 der erste Schultag
nach den Sommerferien Ursula war nach
der Schule noch bei naturnstunde dann
hat sie ihre Cousine besucht und
anschließend radelt sie wie immer am
Ammersee das Stück nach Hause aber zu
Hause ist Ursula Hermann gar nicht erst
angekommen ihre Eltern machen sich
Sorgen melden Sie als vermisst und erste
Wochen später wird Ursula Herrmann
gefunden und zwar begraben in dem
Waldstück am Ammersee im Weingarten in
einer Holzkiste
bildreporterin Lena Zander hat uns in
diese Doppelfolge in einen sehr
spannenden Fall eingeführt in Teil 1
habt ihr gehört wie der Tod von Ursula
Herrmann aus Eching am bayerischen
Ammersee erst zum Cold Case wurde und
fast 30 Jahre später doch noch zu einer
Verurteilung führte der Fall machte mit
traurigen Worten Schlagzeilen
das tote Mädchen aus der Holzkiste diese
Kiste sollte Ursula während einer
erpresserischen Entführung beherbergen
diese Kiste war 1,40 hoch 72 cm breit
und 60 cm tief sie hatte Licht und sogar
ein Belüftungssystem außerdem waren
Getränke und Kekse darin aber die
zehnjährige Ursula erstickte trotz der
belüftungsschläuche wohl schon in den
ersten Minuten erst 27 Jahre nach dem
Verbrechen war die Justiz sicher Werner
matsuregal im fernsehmechaniker aus dem
gleichen Dorf ist der Täter er hat das
Mädchen verschleppt und trotz des frühen
Todes 2 Millionen marköse Geld gefordert
und er hat bei den Eltern angerufen
hauptinsatz der Ermittler ein
altmodisches Tonbandgerät damit soll man
direkt bei den Erpresser anrufen diese
radiokennung abgespielt haben
[Musik]
aber mal zurück beteuert seine Unschuld
das Gerät habe ihr erst 2007 auf einem
Flohmarkt in Niedersachsen gekauft
leider könne er nur noch grob
rekonstruieren von wem und damit sind
wir schon mitten im zweiten Teil dieser
Geschichte ich bin Toni Heyer und ich
bin Mirco Kasimir hallo und schön dass
ihr wieder mit dabei seid
Werner Mazurek ist erst in diesem Jahr
aus dem Gefängnis entlassen worden er
wurde zu lebenslanger Haft verurteilt
kam nach 15 Jahren auf Bewährung frei
aber wie uns Lena Zander berichtet will
er weiter seine Unschuld beweisen für
Werner matzzurek ist es natürlich enorm
wichtig seine Unschuld zu beweisen
sollte er denn wirklich unschuldig sein
denn er hat 15 Jahre hinter Gittern
verbracht das macht was mit einem
Menschen er hat jegliche sozialen
Kontakte die er noch hatte zu Familie
und Co gut das Verhältnis zu seinen
Kindern war immer sehr angespannt aber
er hat letztendlich 15 Jahre hinter
Gittern gesessen und wenn man sich
vorstellt dass er wirklich unschuldig
sein sollte dann ist es schon wichtig
dass man das noch mal aufklärt und auch
für Michael Hermann den Bruder von
Ursula ist es wichtig zu wissen war das
wirklich der wahre Täter oder läuft der
immer noch frei rum
für seine Unschuld macht Werner matsurek
mehrere Dinge geltend zum einen die
Zweifel an der Rolle des tonbandgerätes
und dann ist er auch noch die Spur zum
Landschulheim am Ammersee
beginnen wir mit dem Tonband bei den
schweige Anrufen bei Familie Hermann die
die Polizei aufzeichnete war nur das
verkehrsschingel zu hören und eben die
typischen Nebengeräusche die einen
Tonband macht
[Musik]
passen die Aufzeichnungen von damals zum
Gerät mit der Kennzeichnung Grundig TK
248 das bei Werner Mazurek 2008 gefunden
wurde die Ermittler haben dann auch ein
Gutachten für das Tonbandgerät in
Auftrag gegeben was sie bei der Mama
zurück gefunden hatten und dort konnte
man sagen dass es wahrscheinlich sei das
genau mit diesem Tonband das Bayern
3-signal abgespielt wurde ich habe
darüber auch mit Joachim Feller
gesprochen das ist der Anwalt von
Michael Hermann Michael hermann ist der
Bruder von Ursula Herrmann und der hat
ebenfalls Zweifel daran dass deine Mats
zurück der Schuldige ist und der hat mir
das folgendermaßen eingeordnet und zwar
das ist deine Skala gibt von 1 bis 6
sage ich jetzt mal sehr Leidenschaft und
das wahrscheinlich nur eine Schulnote 3
ist so inzwischen gibt es auch ein neues
Gutachten der Universität Zürich und das
sagt die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass mit
genau diesen Tonbandgerät das war in
drei Signal abgespielt wurde sehr gering
ist aber bisher hat auch das nicht für
ein Wiederaufnahmeverfahren gereicht
okay also die Sache mit dem Tonbandgerät
könnte schon mal für Werner mal zurecht
sprechen aber die Beweisführung scheint
nicht ganz ohne zu sein kommen wir zur
Spur mit dem Namen Landschulheim bei den
ersten Ermittlungen 1981 war die Polizei
zunächst ja schon mal auf Werner mal
zurückgestoßen weil ein alkoholkranker
bekannter ihn beschuldigt hatte trotzdem
wurde weiter ermittelt in Eching und in
der näheren Umgebung wurden
Fingerabdrücke von Männern und
männlichen Teenagern genommen auch im
benachbarten Landschulheim wurden später
Fingerabdrücke genommen Jahrzehnte
später weiß aber eine andere
Ereigniskette wieder zum Internat Werner
mazure lernt einen Mitgefangenen kennen
der von dessen Unschuld überzeugt ist so
sagt es zumindest mal zurecht
der Mann ist ein Unternehmer aus
derselben Region sitzt zeitweise wegen
Steuerhinterziehung in U-Haft und hat
einen Sohn der zum Tatzeitpunkt im
Internat am Ammersee Schüler war der
Junge war gerade zwei Wochen vor Ursulas
verschwinden 18 geworden war er ein
wichtiger Zeuge oder vielleicht sogar
eigentlich verdächtig
bildreporterin Lena Zander war tagelang
in Eching unterwegs und fast zusammen
unweit ist Tatorts ist ein Landschulheim
da gehen die kinderreiche Eltern zur
Schule so und zwei Jahre lang wurde dort
nicht ermittelt sprich es wurden keine
Zeugenbefragung vorgenommen es wurden ja
auch überall im Ort ich war selbst dort
und habe mit Menschen gesprochen die mir
erzählten von uns allen wurden
Fingerabdrücke genommen zwei Jahre lang
wurden aber auch keine Fingerabdrücke in
diesem Land Schulheim genommen erst kurz
bevor es hieß die Polizei kommt jetzt
untersucht das Landschulheim und
ermittelt hier sind zwei Schüler
eigenmächtig zur Polizei gegangen
sie haben einen grünen Klingeldraht
abgegeben dieser grüne Klingeldraht hing
während des Tatzeitpunkt im Weingarten
gespannt eine Vermutung ist dass die
Täter darüber miteinander kommuniziert
haben was ja auch schon sagt dass Werner
matsurek nicht alleine gehandelt haben
kann wenn er wirklich der Täter war was
aber auffällt ist dass diese Schüler ja
gar nicht wissen konnten dass dieser
Klingel Draht in Zusammenhang mit der
Tat steht sie haben gesagt sie haben ihn
beim Eulen jagen durch Zufall entdeckt
mitgenommen und mit aufs Zimmer genommen
was trotzdem auch noch interessant ist
ist Ursula Herrmann wurde am Ammersee
auf einem Weg entführt und durch des
Waldstück rund 800 Meter getragen durch
ganz geheime Trampelpfade auch haben die
Schüler zugegeben dass sie diese
Trampelpfade kannten und benutzt haben
dieser Spur wurde nicht weiter
nachgegangen und ich konnte während
meiner Recherchen auch nicht rausfinden
ob von diesen beiden Schülern
Fingerabdrücke genommen wurden denn auch
sehr seltsam alle Fingerabdrücke die
genommen wurden von landschulheimern die
wurden vernichtet wenn es kein Treffer
gegeben hat für Lena Zander wird immer
deutlicher die Indizienlage gegen Werner
malzurek war von Anfang an dünn ihr
liegen tausende Seiten Aktenmaterial vor
darin taucht auch der Name des Sohnes
von matsurex mit Häftling auf dieser
Geschäftsmann bestätigt zwar auf Lenas
Anfrage die Begegnung mit Mats zurück in
der Krankenstation der JVA aber von
allem anderen habe er keine Kenntnis
aber warum gaben die beiden Schüler
damals überhaupt den Klingeldraht bei
der Polizei ab sie konnten zu dem
Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht wissen dass der
Draht bei Ursula sind Führung eine Rolle
spielte den erst nach der Übergabe
fanden die Ermittler heraus die Täter
könnten den Klingeldraht im Waldgebiet
wohl über die Äste gespannt haben um so
miteinander zu kommunizieren
es könnten also mindestens zwei Täter
gewesen sein außerdem gaben die beiden
Schüler an die geheimen Trampelpfade im
Waldgebiet zu kennen der Entführer soll
diese benutzt haben um Ursula Herrmann
zur vergrabenen Kiste zu schaffen ich
sag's mal so also man wüsste schon gerne
was diese jungen Männer damals wussten
oder vielleicht sogar mit dem Fall zu
tun haben könnten zumal es war keine
Fingerabdrücke vom Tatort hilfreich sind
aber eine andere Spur einer der Schüler
ist auch ein Sohn eines einflussreichen
Geschäftsmannes in Bayern gewesen der
auch möglicherweise gewisse Drähte hatte
und der auch eine
straßenmarkierungsfirma in Bayern hatte
nur ein paar Kilometer entfernt vom
Tatort und was auch interessant ist auf
der Kiste in der Ursula Herrmann
begraben wurde ist ein Deckel extra
angebracht und auf diesem Deckel ist
eine Bitumenschicht Bitumen benutzt man
beim Straßenbau das unter ja auf der
Fahrbahn sind die weißen Streifen da
wird das Drunter geschmiert damit die
Farbe besser hält man hat bis heute
nicht rausgefunden woher dieses Bitumen
stammt man hat diverse hunderte Firmen
in Deutschland außerhalb Deutschlands
angefragt aber auch konnte ich nicht
herausfinden während meiner Recherchen
ob die Firma von diesem einflussreichen
Geschäftsmann angefragt wurde was man
weiß ist dass sie als Experte zu diesem
Thema hinzugezogen wurde
Werner matsurek und sein Anwalt Walter
Rubach versuchen noch mehr sie führen
eine Befragung mit dem Lügendetektor
durch die den mittlerweile 74-Jährigen
entlastet auch Ursula Hermanns Bruder
Michael hat Zweifel daran dass mit
Werner Mats zurück der richtige Täter
verurteilt wurde er beginnt zu
recherchieren und stößt dabei auch auf
die sprachexpertin Barbara aus London
die analysiert unter anderem die
Erpresserbriefe von damals und kommt zu
dem Ergebnis
das Wortwahl und Satzbau nicht zu Werner
matsurics Persönlichkeitsprofil passen
in den Schreiben mit den
ausgeschnittenen Buchstaben werden als
Folge eines Abdrucks sogar mögliche
Spuren von Mathe Schulaufgaben entdeckt
eine Spur ins Internat tja also wie
gesagt die beiden Schüler sind offenbar
sehr interessant für den Fall aber sie
liegen jetzt auch nicht als überzeugende
neue Täter auf dem Silbertablett für sie
gilt das gleiche wie für Mazurek selbst
Indizien und keine harten Beweise und
dann gibt es da noch die Spur zu einem
Polizisten
[Musik]
nennen wir es die polizistenspur der
Polizist Harald wie geriet bereits im
Jahr 1984 ins Visier der Ermittler laut
einem Zeugen wurde sein van ein Ford
Transit am Tag der Entführung von Ursula
Herrmann in der Nähe des Tatorts gesehen
er war dort als Jagdhelfer unterwegs er
kannte sich also sehr gut aus und galt
als handwerklich begabt er eignet sich
durchaus für eine Tat wie die an Ursula
deshalb ließ in die Polizei damals auch
Abhören Ergebnis Harald wie soll mit
seinem Bruder über einen anderen Mann
als der kistenbauer gesprochen haben das
ist schon sehr interessant
und sein Bruder sagte zu einem Freund
dass es schlecht aussehe für Harald und
der eine Strafe von zehn Jahren bis
lebenslänglich auf ihn zukommen sehe der
Polizist führte ein ausschweifendes
Leben und soll Schulden gehabt haben als
Motiv wäre also auch Habgier oder
Geldnot in Frage gekommen
außerdem war er vorbestraft wegen
Körperverletzung während des
Strafprozesses gegen Werner matsueck
sprach auch mal zurück Anwalt Walter
hubach an dass er also der Polizist als
möglicher Täter in Frage käme aber die
Ermittlungen gegen den Polizisten
bringen kein konkretes Ergebnis und
weder beim ersten Strafverfahren gegen
Mats zurück noch bei einer möglichen
Wiederaufnahme des Falls kann er heute
mehr helfen Harald wie starb 1995 im
Alter von nur 46 Jahren mögen die Spuren
zu Werner Mats zurück schon nicht
überzeugend gewesen sein so lassen sich
auch die Hinweise auf andere Täter nur
schwer erhalten und als wäre das alles
nicht vertragt genug gibt es auch noch
eine Panne in dem Fall Lena Zander da
nimmt der Fall noch eine interessante
Wendung und zwar der Parkhaus Mord auch
in München Charlotte Böhringer die dort
ermordet wurde da hat man auf einem
Weinglas DNA gefunden und dieselbe DNA
wurde auch bei der Kiste gefunden von
Ursula Herrmann wie das zustande kommt
die offizielle Begründung der
Staatsanwaltschaft ist das ist ein
zufallstreff als Verunreinigung oder
ähnliches ich habe selbst noch mal
nachgefragt und Zuge meiner Recherchen
und darauf keine weitere Antwort
bekommen
also Spuren von 2006 sollen die gleichen
sein wie 1981
ich finde da liegt eher viel mehr nahe
dass jemand im zuständigen Kriminalamt
da einfach Spuren aus zwei völlig
unterschiedlichen Fällen mit der eigenen
DNA verunreinigt hat auch den Fall
Böhringer haben wir hier schon bei
Tatort Deutschland behandelt ihr findet
ihn mit dem Titel der Parkhaus Mord aber
bei allem Chaos bei allen verwirrenden
Spuren und Rückschlägen kämpft Werner
matsurek auch heute noch weiter um den
Beweis seiner Unschuld auch Ursulas
Bruder Michael Hermann und dessen Anwalt
Joachim Feller ließen nicht locker noch
mal Lena Zander wir haben ja versucht
über den Zivilprozess der hat Michael
Hermann ja Werner matsurek
aufstandsersatz verklagt aufgrund weil
er seine Schwester umgebracht hat und da
haben sie ja das eigentlich nur gemacht
weil sie gehofft haben dadurch in eine
neue Beweisaufnahme eintreten zu können
das ist ja auch ganz spannend und Trick
den man sich da überlegt wenn man sagt
okay wir haben eine neue Beweisaufnahme
und dann heißt es nachher
zivilrechtlich wenn er mal zurück kann
es nicht gewesen gewesen sein dann hat
man diesen ich sag jetzt mal leidenhaft
Beschluss oder dieses Urteil und kann
sagen okay gut das wäre noch ein
Ansatzpunkt für ein
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren dazu kommt aber
noch dass man beachten muss 30 Jahre
erpresserischer Menschen Raub mit
Todesfolge ist verjährt dann muss man
aber noch schauen über Smart weil Mord
ja nie verjährt und Joachim Feller hat
gesagt zu mir dass auch eine Möglichkeit
wäre dass Ursula Herrmann vom Fahrrad
gerissen wurde mit Lachgas betäubt wurde
und dann in die Kiste verschafft wurde
das heißt wenn man jemand mit Lachgas
betäubt dann muss man davon ausgehen
dass dieser Mensch auch daran stirbt und
dann wäre das Vorsatz und dann hätte man
Mord als Strafbestand hat also da
müssten viele Dinge zusammen kommen
überhaupt einen Wiederaufnahme Verfahren
in Gang zu bringen aber interessantes
auf jeden Fall
jetzt haben wir sehr viel über und mit
dem Verurteilten in diesem Fall
gesprochen und natürlich macht seine
zweifelhafte Rolle die Geschichte auch
über die Jahrzehnte so spannend aber am
Ende finde ich sollten wir einfach mal
einen Augenblick an Ursula Herrmann
denken das ist ein wirklich guter Punkt
Toni die zehn Jahre alte Ursula wollte
einfach nur von ihren Verwandten im
Nachbarort nach Hause nichts hat sie auf
eine heimtückische Entführung
vorbereitet und schon gar nicht hat sie
verdient was ihr zugestoßen ist
vielleicht wollte ihr in Führer sie
nicht töten aber er hat es in Kauf
genommen und ich finde das Schlimme ist
dass wenn wir über diese Fälle sprechen
klar wir reden viel über die Täter aber
die Opfer diesen eigentlich die größten
Verlierer in diesem Fall zusammen mit
den Familien und die kommen oft viel zu
kurz die Opfer die sollten und die
dürfen wir auch nie vergessen
[Musik]
und damit sind wir am Ende unseres
heutigen falls vielen Dank dass ihr mit
dabei waren Redaktion hatten Lena Zander
und Stefan Netze Band Aufnahme und
schnittproduktion durch die weight watch
Studios München bis zum nächsten mal
euer Mirko und eure tun